.
>> Laura: MAY BE JUST TO TELL
THEM THAT THERE ARE PLENTY OF
CAMERAS DOWN THERE.
THANK YOU.
>> THERE ARE MORE THAN 250
PROPOSED BILLS AND AT LEAST 43
STATES AIMED AT RESTRICTING
ACCESS TO THE BALLOT.
IT'S BEING CALLED THE NEW JIM
CROW.
>> THIS IS RACIAL VOTER
SUPPRESSION YOU'VE HEARD THE
WORDS JIM CROW.
WE DON'T ENJOY SAYING IT BUT IT
IS WHAT IT IS.
>> WHAT WE SEE IS JIM CROW 2.0.
LET'S CALL IT WHAT IT IS.
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
IT'S SAD.
>> Laura: HAS SENATOR GRAHAM
MENTIONED, YOU HEAR A LOT OF
THAT, THE NEW GEORGIA LAW.
IT'S LIKE WHAT EXISTED IN THE
OLD SOUTH EVERY THOUGHT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE OLD SOUTH.
WHAT HE JIM CROW LAWS ACTUALLY
LOOK LIKE.
HERE'S ONE.
NO COLORED BARBARA SHALL HAVE
SERVICE OF BARBER TO WHITE WOMEN
OR GIRLS.
CHILDREN WHY PEOPLE EXCLUSIVELY
OR COLORED PEOPLE EXCLUSIVELY.
IT SHOULD BE UNLAWFUL FOR A
WHITE PERSON TO MARRY ANYONE
EXCEPT A WHITE PERSON.
HERE TOY AND IS UTAH CONGRESSMAN
BURGESS OWENS.
YOUR DATA ACTUALLY GREW UP IN
THE JIM CROW SOUTH.
WHEN YOU HEAR THE CONSTANT
REPETITION OF GEORGIA IS JIM
CROW, YOU MUST HAVE A PRETTY
ENRAGED RESPONSE.
>> MY DAD AND MY GRANDDAD AND SO
DID I.
I WAS 16 YEARS OLD WHEN I HAD A
CHANCE TO EXPERIENCE EATING
WHITE AMERICANS.
I GREW UP IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
WAS SEGREGATED.
PROUD COMMUNITY.
I AM SICK AND TIRED OF THE HARD
LEFT, BLACK LEADERS PUTTING MY
RACE DOWN OF THE GREATEST
GENERATION THAT EVER LIVED OUT
THAT MY DAD, GRANDDAD'S
GENERATION.
THEY LOVED OUR COUNTRY.
THEY WERE ABOUT MERITOCRACY AND
PROVING THAT THEY ARE WORTHY OF
RESPECT.
SO TO HEAR THAT WE ARE HALF THIS
HOPELESS RACE, THAT'S MARXISM
ALIVE.
THAT'S NOT THE PARENTS I WAS
RAISED WITH.
I'M THANKFUL I GREW UP AROUND
THE PEOPLE I DID IN THE 1960s.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, THEY
REFUSE TO BE REFERRED TO AS
VICTIMS.
INSTEAD THEY ACTED LIKE
CHAMPIONS.
HERE WE HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
BIDEN IS DEMANDING THAT THE
ALL-STAR GAME LEAVE ATLANTA?
LET'S REMIND EVERYONE OF WHAT
JIM CROW WAS ACTUALLY LIKE FOR
BASEBALL PLAYERS IN GEORGIA.
IT SHALL BE UNLAWFUL FOR ANY
AMATEUR COLORED BASEBALL TEAM TO
PLAY BASEBALL IN ANY VACANT LOT
OR BASEBALL DIAMOND WITHIN TWO
BLOCKS OF ANY PLAYGROUND DEVOTED
TO THE WHITE RACE.
CONGRESSMAN.
THIS ONLY ILLUSTRATES, DOES IT
NOT, WHY THIS BASEBALL GAME
ABSOLUTELY MUST BE PLAYED IN
GEORGIA?
>> IT IS AND LET ME SAY I CAME
IN THE NFL IN 1973, THERE WERE
NO BLACK QUARTERBACKS, CENTERS,
MIDDLE LINEBACKERS.
WHITE MEN IN LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS.
WE'VE COME SO FAR.
IT'S NOT EVEN AN ISSUE.
WHAT WE HAVE IS PEOPLE WHO SAY
THAT THEY ARE COMPASSIONATE AND
THEY LOVE MY RACE AND OTHER
RACES.
IF THEY WANTED DEAL, HEARING
ABOUT THIS VOTER I.D. FOR 20
YEARS.
IF THEY CARED ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE
BEING ABLE TO GET ON THE PLANE,
HAVE A JOB IN A SAVINGS ACCOUNT,
MOVE INTO THE MIDDLE CLASS, THEY
WOULD'VE DONE SOMETHING BY NOW.
THEY LOVE TO USE MISERY AS A
POLITICAL STRATEGY.
I WANT MY DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS TO
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A HARD LEFT
MARXIST SOCIALIST ABUSING YOUR
GOOD HURTS TO DESTROY OUR
NATION.
DON'T LET THEM.
WE'VE GOT TO COME TOGETHER AND
REALIZE WE HAVE THE SAME
END GAME.
THAT OUR KIDS HAVE THE BEST
FUTURE POSSIBLE AND WE LIVE IN
SAFETY AND IT WILL NEVER HAPPEN
WITH THE HARD LEFT.
THEY ARE GODLESS, THEY HIT THE
FAMILY AND THEY HATE CAPITALISM.
DESTROYING OUR NATION FROM
WITHIN.
LET'S NOT LET THEM DO THAT.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN,
FINALLY, HOW DID WE GET TO A
POINT IN TIME IN OUR COUNTRY
WHERE DEMOCRATS APPARENTLY THINK
SO LITTLE OF MINORITY VOTERS
THAT THEY JUST ASSUME THEY DON'T
HAVE IDs.
WHAT IS THAT?
IT IS SO INSULTING.
>> THINK ABOUT IT.
WHAT OTHER RACE TO THEY THINK,
ASIAN, POLISH, ITALIAN?
NO.
ONLY BLACK PEOPLE.
HERE'S THE THING.
THEY RECOGNIZE BLACK METAL
AMERICANS ARE LEAVING THE
PLANTATION.
THEY WANT THE WALLS COME DOWN.
THEY WANT --
WHAT MARXISTS DO IF THEY LOVE
CHAOS.
IT'S ON PURPOSE.
THEY LOVE TO NOT THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE FUTURE IS LIKE.
>> Laura: REWRITING HISTO